many things to talk about in this first
portion of today's friday show first i
want to follow up on a story from
earlier this week earlier this week we
talked about
former fox news host bill o'reilly
absolutely losing it at an airport
treating jetblue employees terribly
because their flight to turks and caicos
was running very very late well the man
who
supports the party of personal
responsibility and supports taking
responsibility and holding people
accountable for their actions he says
really this is biden's problem
and it's because of biden that he
flipped out on a uh on a worker at the
airport as a reminder let's start with
the original clip this is bill o'reilly
at jetblue in jfk airport threatening to
get a worker fired and demanding his
name and aggressively leaning towards
the guy and all
[Music]
listen flight delays suck it's not the
gate agent's fault like i said you don't
treat people like this and now he starts
with the threatening for losing your job
is
[Music]
you're going to lose your job so anyway
that was the incident and now we have an
explanation from bill o'reilly
and uh he's blaming biden i don't know
guys maybe there's something to it
bill o'reilly says it's biden's fault he
threw a fit and
the statement is on tuesday o'reilly
tweeted the character assassins on
social media are completely lying about
my interaction with the jetblue guy who
misled passengers during a five-hour
delay i expected this speaking to
mediaite o'reilly acknowledged that he
handled the situation poorly
and could have used different words but
refused to apologize he claimed numerous
people recognized him and they started
asking him about the hold up he almost
became like a union rep guys so bill
o'reilly was just speaking for the
people that's what was going on he
insisted the heat on him is a
distraction from the real story which is
that jetblue is subpar the story is
jetblue can't get their flights off the
ground it was crazy in the terminal
um for some reason the biden
administration is not big on solving
problems and this is a huge problem how
this has to do with joe biden i truly
have no idea and the story here remember
there's two stories here
one story is they say they're all about
personal responsibility
when they do something when they choose
to behave a certain way
and it's horrible and they get called
out they blame somebody else and of
course secondly it's
they always insist in political
discussions you must state your
principles give me your list of
principles here and one of the
principles is personal responsibility as
soon as the principles are inconvenient
they ignore the principles they abandon
the principles and that's the way it
works and as i said before and i'll say
it again
i have been
so frustrated some of the most
frustrating situations i can remember
relate to airlines once
my flight was just canceled there was no
reason wait but so is there a technical
problem no
is there a weather problem
no
the flight has been cancelled
never an explanation i lost a day but
that we're rebooking you tomorrow
you want to start screaming at people
but you don't because you realize it's
not this person's fault and my guess
when o'reilly says that they were being
misled i know that feeling it's very
common when you fly that they say uh
folks
we uh have just there's a light on
that's on the plane and we want
maintenance to look at it
it's just gonna be ten minutes until
they get here so we're gonna hold off on
boarding for now okay well ten minutes
go by and they say we're we're still
waiting for maintenance and finally
maintenance gets there but they said it
was 10 minutes for maintenance to get
there they didn't say anything else so
maintenance has uh identified a problem
and we're going to look for a part here
and if we get it it's only about an hour
fix once we find the part okay
45 minutes go by
we've not been able to find the part it
is an hour fix once we find the part but
this actually happened to me in las
vegas they said the closest part right
now is in san diego we found the part
and it's only an hour to install it but
it's coming in on a san diego flight
that flight leaves san diego in a half
hour very short flight but now you're
doing math you're going okay wait so
we're already 75 minutes delayed
the flight doesn't leave for 45. then it
takes 45 and then they got to get the
part and then it's another hour and then
and then you get to now fortunately this
didn't happen to me but then the classic
is our our crew has timed out they now
are mandated to rest which i have no
problem with we want everybody to be
rested i don't want unrested crew and
pilots flying
and then you lose a day i mean listen i
i get it these things are frustrating
you don't start treating people like
crap that's really the principle we
should all be sticking to bill o'reilly
blaming everybody but himself
one of our sponsors is blissey giving
you 30
off blissey offers the nicest luxury
silk pillowcases you have ever felt on
your face i've been sleeping with blissy
pillowcases at home i have tried many
pillowcases the feel of blissey beats
them all every blissy pillow case is
made with 100
mulberry silk they're hypoallergenic
they are just super soft the type of
silk that blissey uses stays cool all
night even after using it for hours it's
still cool and perfect i get too hot
when i sleep the cooling factor makes a
big difference the protein based silk
blissey uses is also moisture wicking
which helps if you get sweaty while you
sleep blissey has earned high praise
from a ton of publications like good
housekeeping you can read their reviews
online blissy is having a huge mother's
day sale right now giving you 30 off
when you go to blissy.com
and the link is down below